the Joe Rogan experience and that's
always been fascinating to me is when
you see like the study of the law of
attraction where it's like you see
something you like how your pupils
dilate and how you how you kind of like
pheromones and weird [ __ ] I got a
cologne god I can't remember what the oh
it was called so that's your blacks
cologne huh
okay guys what am i wondering well who
the [ __ ] buying Cologne me clothes you
have in your house I probably have about
like 10 whoa
beer connoisseur yeah do you have like
different like tonight is the night yeah
no I sign up for scent bird with that
said scent bird is the Cologne they send
you a different cologne every month
it's a cologne club it's like Dollar
Shave Club it's like free fun it's like
14.95 you get a little violent cologne
Christ hey I've been with them for two
three years scent burr oh my god but I
do it every every year I'll go I'll have
my January through my December smells
you have different this is a different
time get the [ __ ] out okay well that's a
wrap it smells four different times of
the year yeah I got my spring I got my
summer I got my fall and I got I got a
little spicy at the end of the year
though oh she gets spicy towards the
fall in the winter yeah yeah we're like
a pumpkiny sort of a sauna man
no just like vodka dolce & gabbana
little dragon bone a little bit uh yeah
and they have them all on there and
they're nice have you I've always
smelled good okay I like people are like
today me smell good I'm like [ __ ] out
you're right you put like a tiny bit
tiny bit just a touch just that's it but
you have ten yeah so and they keep
sending you more mmm are you worried
gonna run out of space
he's wallowing in his own filth no I
have I have usually I'll use for the
month I'll use that as my month and then
you know if I don't use them I'll save
them oh but there is evil there is a
cologne that I had it was called sexual
sexual has any
word [ __ ] it's some [ __ ] let's
like go heading this is how you say like
when people would say in Spanish can you
tell me where o is the restaurant oh oh
yeah actually thanks you out but it had
pheromones in it sure it did
so it had pheromones in it and every
time I would wear it women would be like
mmm
hey yeah good as they probably took some
fat guy and made him run on a treadmill
and then they'd ripped his [ __ ]
underwear in each bottle it's just Oh
dip Bert Kreischer no he's he's thick
with two so he's just Google Burton's
not you'll find I know but the duh
that's mean he's thick Tom and Bert we
call each other fat the bear fat shamed
each other what is it the butt yeah but
he wears one k bears yeah that's a
chance of K term tell them she tell them
that they should know they probably may
be stunned have to change your bears one
cave they're both bears in the gay
community those are bears so they didn't
get the joke they don't get the
reference think they know they should
are they technically bears you have to
be kind of little buff to be a bear no
no no just hairy yeah fat I don't know
what you are you're not a beard huh a
chimp no yeah what is Joe Rogan in the
gay community hmm
that's I think that's why we I don't
have a thing either good
congratulation I used to be a twink and
now I'm not and now I've wet wilts my
Harry what changed
I grew up Joe yeah I'm mature I felt
that issue with gay folks right as you
get older the older guys that are
straight can get hoes oh absolutely gold
diggers yeah
yeah I love a good old ho I know some
dudes who are just really old and they
have young hot girlfriends or wives
oh yeah it's hilarious cuz they got that
job yeah but then that doesn't work
who guys does it yeah it does for twinks
right it does for young gays to young
gay there's definitely some where I've
been like this guy's like 85 years old
it's like said nineteen year old oh yeah
like yeah oh yeah but that's okay in the
gay community where
that's disgusting in the straight
community if you see an 80 year old guy
with an 18 year old girl you want to
beat him to death you piece of [ __ ] but
if you see an 8 year old gay guy with an
18 year old boy like Oh found himself a
fella yeah okay you also can look and be
like that'll do Pig well you know also
the other way if you find 80 year old
lady she's got a 24 year old boyfriend
well yeah go girl go [ __ ] you go mm-hmm
good for her good for her nobody's mad
at her yeah
if anything you're mad at the guy for
like playing that old lady and getting
her to buy you a Corvette
[Applause]